hi I'm potion lo I'm a math professor
here at Carnegie Mellon University and I
also run a startup company to teach
everyone math and science at X P exp III
comm hi I'm kelcie kögel I graduated
from CMU in 2007 and one of my favorite
times of year was always when the number
pi was chalked all over campus and that
later inspired one of my art projects I
currently work as a freelance food
stylist event designer passionate Baker
I have a food blog called with the
grains and I use that as a way to
celebrate pi day each year right pi well
PI can make me hungry when there's a
prize sitting here especially if I
haven't had lunch yet but actually when
I find very fascinating about pi is that
it can be used to show people how
unusual numbers can be because for
example when we're small we start
counting so we could say there are two
plates if I were to put two plates down
okay well the distance from this side of
that side is like two I mean if this is
one that's two similarly with forks I
could say well if I were to put them
side by side here I just got two forks
with a distance but these are very nice
numbers and actually it turns out that
you can get a very strange number very
easily and that's what piqued somebody's
people's imagination suppose I wanted to
be an ant going all the way around and
see how far that is compared to going
straight across you find out that ratio
the fraction it becomes something that
you can't just write simply it's not -
it's not even a simple number like
square root of 2 it's actually simply
called transcendental and we see numbers
like this written across across the
decorations in schools all the time and
so I think it's one of these fascinating
numbers that people can very easily
explain but then maybe it's a bit hard
to wrap your head around at the same
time but something else I like to say
also is that this is the first thing
that people think about when they think
about pie but the amazing thing about
pie is actually it comes in many other
ways as well pie can appear in another
area of mathematics where actually what
you're doing is maybe let me give an
example this way if you're saying I have
a line of people like a hundred people
and I wasn't know how many different
ways can I line up those people this is
a
factorial it's like hundred with this
exclamation point which we often teach
in combinatorics class here at CMU and
many people see in high school and so it
turns out that you can approximate this
with a formula and that formula is
called Sterling's approximation it has a
PI inside it as well so now that's
that's that's like a way where pi
appears when you're even thinking about
how to rearrange people in a line so you
have this marvelous PI here I'm curious
what got you into the PI for pi day well
I was a CMU student and I looked forward
to the tradition every year of the
numbers being chalked all over campus
and then I graduated and went into the
world and found that not everyone shared
that same punny allegiance to 2pi but I
did so I did an art project called the
cutie pie project and my initials are QT
and I made pies from all local
ingredients and then I boxed them in a
little recipe boxes and delivered them
the ax by sickle to Holmes with 3 1 4
addresses on pi day so pi on pi and pi
the artist statement essentially so what
exactly are we gonna do with this pi now
we're definitely gonna eat that pie oh
this sounds great
so how does this work when you make this
this is this is a very unique pie it
doesn't quite look like apple or
cranberry no that's something different
yeah it's a savory pie because I was
inspired by Carnegie Mellon in Scotland
and in the UK in general I guess there's
a rich tradition of peasant food all
these hearty comforting foods and if you
ever feel one of these really authentic
meat pies they are bulky but I think
baking and cooking should be fun and you
should find inspiration and then riff
off that so it's a bunch of things mixed
together for my Scottish interpretation
excellent it's always great to fuse
education and entertainment and well
even better is lucky
you